hello Halloween errs welcome back to
October top five I'm Walter Bernays and
I'm Heather Ruth every week this month
will feature Halloween themed countdowns
and today we dive into our first worst
list
not every goosebumps monster can be as
cool as the dog who barks in the intro
though I love that what's with the
button every time I press it a clip of
the goosebumps dog barking plays see
this is gonna get really annoying is it
goose bumps had its fair share of good
and bad villains last week we looked at
the best monsters the show had to offer
but just as I spoke of last year not
every episode of this series was good in
fact a decent portion of these stories
and characters don't hold up well now or
even back then keeping in line with our
previous episode I will not be counting
the villains featured in last year's top
5 worst goosebumps episodes there are
more terrible monsters to cover and I
intend on breaking those down right now
these are the top 5 worst where's Diana
oh I'm sure she just took the week off
he's probably fine these are the top 5
you're trying to tell me that the same
woman who is kidnapped by
interdimensional clones of you a couple
of months ago is nowhere to be found and
you have absolutely no questions
whatsoever pertaining to our whereabouts
yep these are the top 5 worst
goosebumps monsters number 5 the swamp
monster and how to kill a monster how do
you kill a swamp monster apparently
there are many ways by the way spoiler
warning for all these episodes
Gretchen's father just married the
mother of Craig its Clark yeah whatever
they're visiting Gretchen's grandparents
while the newlywed couple is on their
honeymoon unfortunately for the kids
these elderly folks live in the middle
of a swamp and seem to be hiding
something from them strange noises
continuously come from the storage room
upstairs and eventually Gretchen and
Clark find out the swamp isn't just home
to snails and frogs the newly minted
step-siblings in this episode are your
garden-variety 90 stereotypes
needless to say they don't get along
very well you are toast toast toast what
are you doing oh it's just thing I do
before you time this monster had the
potential to be really cool I like the
design and the weird elephant roar it
makes plus it almost looks like a Putra
pod from Power Rangers turbo my main
issue with this monster is how its
totally wasted in the episode it's set
up pretty well but this thing dies more
than Crillon Dragon Ball Z
it finally bites the dust' for good
after Clark accidentally shoves his hand
in its mouth
apparently it's allergic to humans and
dies almost immediately the monster then
explodes covering the kids in slime
leaving no doubt that it's finally gone
for good what a weak waste of a great
design number four the werewolves and
werewolf skin this concept is really
what led these monsters onto our worst
list Alex Blackwell is staying with his
aunt and uncle for a while they live in
Wolf Creek which has a rather odd
reputation for the supernatural namely
werewolves Alex doesn't waste time in
breaking the rules set by his interim
Guardians as he investigates an old
creepy house nearby and goes into the
woods alone at night the young
photographer is looking to win a horror
themed picture contest by capturing a
compelling creepy image however when
those werewolf stories start to look
like more fact than fiction alex has a
hard time finding people he can trust
including his uncle Colin and aunt Marta
Marta I said what's so the concept here
is that werewolves shut their skin
during the day and put it back on at
night I guess they're drawn back to the
skin nightly in our compelled like
zombies our two brains to keep putting
the living skin back on unlike the
werewolf of fever swamp werewolf skin
mishandles this legendary monster type I
give credit to RL Stein for trying a new
idea with them but it just comes off as
so lame in the episode theoretically it
should be pretty easy to defeat them
just keep the skin away from the humans
who put it on you don't even have to
wait until morning before the skin
explodes into flames freeing the humans
of their curse this two-parter had a
couple well-done trademark goosebumps
moments but overall it's just a cheap
plot device was it handled better in the
book comment below and leave your
thoughts number 3 Clarissa and be
careful what you wish for I know what
you're thinking and no she's not nearly
as cool as the real Clarissa Samantha
Byrd is a clumsy basketball player at
her school who is constantly mocked by
bully Judith one day Samantha helps out
a woman named Clarissa
who was trying to find her way home to
repay her kindness Clarissa tell
Samantha that she will grant her three
wishes samantha is confused at first but
soon starts to realize that Clarissa is
the real deal kind of I know there are
big differences from the book to the
episode so maybe that's why this
character just doesn't work but Clarissa
is not an interesting personality for
Samantha to bounce off of I shall grant
you
three she's her gimmick is that she's
bad at her job so whatever Samantha
makes a wish it doesn't turn out the way
she meant it wishes are complicated
magic isn't an exact science you know
great I'm not sure what they were trying
to go for with Clarissa bumbling witch
with good intentions or one of those you
learn your lesson because you wished in
the first place kind of characters it's
confusing and unfocused which sort of
ruins whatever moral they were trying to
push and of course we have the
worst-looking statue effect I've ever
seen at the end of the episode to just
skip this one if you're we watching this
series number two mr. Blankenship in
teacher's pet ever want to see a Dave
Grohl look-alike in a goosebumps episode
too bad you got it Becca and Benji
joined their class for a sleepover in a
nature preserve but one of their
teachers mr. Blankenship is acting
weirder than usual when strange
crossbred animals start showing up in
the woods Becca and Benji investigate
further and find a shack with many
peculiar experiments on going their trip
to the Nature Preserve was supposed to
be about learning how the food chain
works but they end up discovering
they're on the wrong end of it just
listen to this guy talk I mean at least
crossbreed animals that could actually
be interesting together I don't think
anyone ever asked for a cheetah turtle
or a lizard rabbit and of course he
turns out to be a snake man hey wait a
minute
no no he's dead
dead I was dead I killed him and the
number one worst goosebumps monster is
the gruel and it came from beneath the
sink
it's a sponge sponges aren't scary you
can't make sponges scary I'm sorry they
can be funny hilarious even but scary
sponges can't do it not today
cat Merton finds an evil sponge in her
new house that's causing all sorts of
havoc later her family finds out it's
actually a grool a mythical creature
that gains strength from the bad luck of
anyone around it seemingly
indestructible the Martin children have
a more than difficult time disposing of
this belligerent being I'm not sure
what's worse the sponge itself or the
music they used to defeat it makes you
want a cute
yeah but why does it make you want to
puke it's so happy this one speaks for
itself
while goosebumps is known for its goofy
villains the gruel wipes the floor with
its competition this is the x5 no no
it's not this week at my personal
channel I look back at 2015's goosebumps
theatrical movie did it do the show and
books justice based off of it what can
we expect from this week's release of
goosebumps - haunted Halloween reviews
of both those films will be up on the
awesome walter youtube channel so check
it out for more goosebumps content as
October rolls along we want to hear what
you guys think what is your least
favorite goosebumps monster what do you
want to see us cover next on the show
leave a comment and let us know to keep
in touch you could like my Facebook page
or follow along on Twitter and you can
find me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter
I stream on Wednesday nights well catch
you right back here next week with
something a little more mysterious on a
brand-new episode of October top 5 the
truth is out there yeah I intend to find
it
if you won't help me look for Ayane I'll
do it myself give me that
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]